first day in Tahoe it's our exploration
day and honestly it's been awesome
having our dogs trained because we're so
well behaved I'm just waiting in the
hallway and look at the beach guys which
is healing and waiting and being good
goggles hey what I was just getting your
compliment just stood up okay here let's
go
okay monkey tell everyone where we are
where are we dude
look whoa yeah
see the water yeah I don't see any water
it's always oh careful oh God
you see I see it it's right there
let me hold it what the hell but we'll
always do this thing where he gets a
bright idea and then he'll just start
vlogging without telling me and I'm like
bro I could just Vlog let me just hold
the camera please God Jesus Christ
okay monkey so tell us where we are
right now
they're right there good job
traffic a little bit oh God there's
traffic oh man
even this guy those traffic's bad
or it's gonna take us more traffic no I
don't know like oh God no not really oh
there's no traffic anywhere else yay
yeah this traffic only has one how
pretty this drive is
it yeah it's gonna be 33 minutes
where are we going to this place called
what which is this place called Bonsai
rock yeah I left to make a left right
there there's a place called Bonsai Rock
and what's cool is it's like a very
Scenic and photogenic place
but it's not really on the map so that's
what makes it cool because it's not
easily visitable it's for people that
really want to search it on look at it
but it looks it's all the Instagram
beautiful yeah spots it's Instagram spot
where you see like a chick and her
golden retrieve retrieval retriever on a
paddle board and they're just paddling
amongst like this like this glass Lake
and you just see these big ass Boulder
rocks so if you've seen that on
Instagram
that's where we're going I like to see
the water now yeah
no not more traffic but that's gorgeous
they're like a more attractive oh no
well we'll be all right
we'll make it oh there that's it see
it's right there and then we have to do
a little high grip to search for it
because there's no actual coordinates
that puts you on Bonsai Rockwell I know
I even looked at like all hikes and
there was nothing all Trail all Trail on
me yeah you have to find it which is all
the blog posts you know so you have to
kind of find it but it's not hard to
find yeah we just kind of head towards
the water it's it makes sense
so if you watched yesterday's Vlog this
is the rock we were talking about the
tunnel hole Rock we don't know what it's
called
called something I forgot I remembered
it last time but this already came out
last time and you see Lake Tahoe and
it's like gorgeous yeah it is hold your
breath ready you have to hold your
breath ready I'll tell you hold your
breath go don't breathe don't breathe
don't breathe we're almost there and you
make a wish and it'll come true make a
wish and Let It Go
yeah how did it feel I I I I
didn't I I was holding my brother but I
didn't
okay good
you okay
I'm not going to get knocked out got it
okay and then the water is all all cobra
every time I want to talk about what I
want to show it can't see it anymore
it's taking over the world
the water sticking over the world
okay excuse me what
and look at the water over there that's
not the sky baby that's the water
but look at this scenic view monkey what
are your thoughts right now
oh okay he has nothing to say look at
that water
water holy cow there's two Skies one
right here
yeah the sky water and then just Sky air
look at this it's gorgeous if I don't
see a bear
I'm not gonna be happy I'm just kidding
I don't need a super there's people
cycling over here oh man Tahoe is
gorgeous this looks like a road where
they always shoot like a Porsche
commercial yeah it's all windy it looks
really nice
and you like right here this patch
yeah thank you baby
so right now at this point we're trying
to figure out where are they going what
do they know look at them they know
something's cool down there these guys
too and they have all the water stuff
these guys are locals they know what's
going on
do you think it's like here somewhere no
where are you going well I'm trying to
find you're going to whale Beach well it
bronzai Rock oh so I'm trying to find it
trying to get as close as I can uh the
blog did say you want to get to a part
where where you park you can see it oh
and you can figure out the trail down
there so that makes a lot of sense so
I'm trying to get visibility on Bonsai
Rock first got it
come on are you kidding me right now
how gorgeous is all
of it I freaking love this truck because
it's gear Central I have all of our
water gear fins snorkels doggy life
vests water shoes
and mama's putting that on
the Young Buck right now
so the way I like to arrive why I like
to have a geared out truck is that's
kind of like your home base right like
kind of like your base camp and in that
way you can travel look at the area and
then know which a piece of gear is the
best so we arrived here I brought Crocs
I brought tennis shoes and I'm looking
at this environment I'm like water shoes
is probably the best Jesus Christ the
water is insane
this is gorgeous is this not gorgeous
this is freaking beautiful
it's beautiful
I'm sorry all right so the instructions
say to find a trail we found one right
here we're just gonna go down this way
there's many ways to get down there
so this one's the most convenient so
we're just gonna head down it is quite
slippery
but that looks so freaking worth it is
incredible
this view is freaking
wow
oh my goodness
okay so we made it to Bonsai Beach or
Bonsai Rock
and although the blocks it to come early
we did come pretty early it's like
before eight but even then
it's full of people which is cool and
everyone's on a paddle board I think
that's the way to go that's where the
water's super clear
but we're looking for something a little
more remote
where we can hang out so I'm gonna run
ahead in that direction
but the water is extremely clear though
insane
we're going through some straight dense
Trails trying to find a dope remote spot
because lots of people out here
I'm just scared of too many gaps at the
Rocks don't know how to jump that's the
hard way okay he's a good Explorer
my backpack sure well you got a caliber
gear behind oh no give me a catch oh
smart good job
do you want to go that way or you want
to go up this way and around we could
try that okay I mean this way looks the
easiest but we could really eat the dogs
yeah for the dogs okay let's go
this way watch your hand watch your hand
i'm gonna put my foot here okay
what about your toe
how did that even happen
that's all you gotta wait Mister
so it's definitely a dead end we went
this way and the Rocks just drop off on
that side
which looks very cool but when you got a
little kid
and some doggies
and two baby doggies at that
we can't really do that
what Chinese right there I have someone
left some Chinese here too
mamia Cooper let's go
some of these places are pretty dicey
like literally to get across where mama
is
you literally have to crawl through here
and then up and under
because it's pretty tall unless you're
like six four you can't just cross over
this way it's an adventure and that's
the watch put that thing behind me don't
hit my head get low enough
squeeze my back back in
and
climb through
this is
an adventure for sure
good job doggy
all right so we came all the way back up
to the street to find a better route
because it's hard to find paths once
it's all Rocky so the truck is up there
mama and taika are right behind me I'm
kind of like the Ford Recon Scout here
but I found this trail that goes
straight down there where the water
looks crystal clear so that should be
good
this is pretty cool we're straight up
going into like dense Woods
[Music]
good job Cooper good job Cooper
cutie Cooper swimming
hey koopy coops
my little swimmer
oh Mia's wet too
Camille wants to swim too
good job koopy coops
he's not me she's shaking off her water
okay get your backpack mister I'm not
good at swimming yeah but you're really
good at climbing I've been seeing you do
ninja moves you're gonna move back over
there okay that's the best spot Mama
found the best spot
ready
let's go
put on your backpack so it's easy to
remove
stuff see now you're in a bad position
come on put on your backpack
yeah put up put it on
there you go good job
now it's gonna be easy to move
good job there you go
nice
um okay I'm medium
I'm the number one
you're the number one climber okay let's
go
CUNY Mia
um
yeah he was not drowning yes I was over
there hopeless
he is so adventurous
yeah you're awesome you are pretty good
awesome
what are you eating you're always eating
back in the hotel room for lunch
and the CUNY family got some taco busy
what did you get mister
oh that looks so good the Doritos you
got the Doritos tacos yeah
that's your favorite you like Taco Bell
more than McDonald's now or no yeah do
you want me to eat the meat yeah yeah oh
careful careful oh that's the delicious
crunch oh you like the meat there it's
really good huh the mama got what you
get I think you got a loaded bag yeah I
don't even know you don't know I think
you have a contract coin drop Supreme
two chalupas
two crunchy tacos and what else it's at
least four items yeah that's it this one
is more
I think that's it and how I know is
because I was sent in to go get it and
when I walked in I was like
what I'm having is I went back to
Safeway got myself a roasted chicken
because what's cool about these guys is
um I can get about 90 grams of protein
with under 10 grams of fat out of the
breasts and then the other stuff I get
to share with these little fur balls so
they're happy I'm happy and I'm trying
to make it where I have enough space to
eat something decently yummy for dinner
because I've had just straight chicken
for two days in a row because we've been
traveling and when I'm traveling I'm
trying to stay extra under because I
don't have a scale so I'm still trying
to do what I can to maintain CUNY funny
fun times with the fam eat lunch
together while still maintaining my diet
which is a little bit difficult but
we're doing it yeah in the first video
we actually made a mistake and the last
time at last at our house mom ate four
tacos mama ate four tacos
yes
I like seeing you young man I like
seeing you in the mirror because you're
cute
Beauty he's got a CUNY face he looks
like someone I know
so I literally just stick my hands in
the back and rip out two chicken breasts
and that's 12 ounces
pretty good amount of protein that might
even be 100 this time I saw some chicken
thighs and stuff in there but I I could
probably eat that for tomorrow but I do
give them the skin and then the wings
because the wings are delicious but if
you're extremely fatty so I can't be
having that I'll eat this with a little
bit of ketchup
with a little bit of these Snyder so I
found some Snyder nibblers these
sourdough nibblers it's only a 0.5 grams
of fat so I'm really happy about this so
this will be my my little food action
right here and I found that 10 calorie
10 calorie drinks
actually not too bad
no actually it looks sad after the lake
we uh took a fat nap all three of us are
extremely tired we all passed out me
taika Geo and the dogs and then we
worked for a little bit and I stayed in
the room to work just a little bit more
and now we're catching them in the pool
dude that was pretty cool dude
that was pretty cool young man
that was crazy both uh oh I think he
just got in trouble I don't think mama
wants him to do that in a public pool
where he could Splash other people but
anyways I'm glad I caught that on camera
because I don't know if I caught it on
camera last time in the Vlog but now
we're going to spend some time in the
pool swim around Splash around I do have
like 900 something calories left in the
day so hopefully we could catch a yummy
dinner I also heard there's a hot tub
too oh okay yeah so it goes the pools in
here and it goes out there's that whole
outdoor area and then there's a hot tub
over there so that's going to be pretty
relaxing
so Mama Bear had a really CUNY idea
where she was like why don't we look for
a pet friendly restaurant and then we
can walk into town and then eat there
and good thing that our hotel is
actually really close to town my Town's
right there so we're walking with these
furry guys
getting them used to town and we get to
see the town on foot that's a good idea
Mama thank you baby
is
that's a big dog whoa
whoa he's walking around by himself
yeah yeah super trained
okay we're gonna make a left at that
light up there okay mister
is that light
no the traffic light
so we ended up finding this pet friendly
restaurant called Maggie's and what's so
cool is it's on the third floor of this
really dope looking hotel look at this
hotel every single hotel has a back a
balcony
and it has a swinging chair
and it looks super like modern Farmhouse
and that's Maggie's that's like one side
of it and um since you have a bigger
party with three people and two dogs
they're gonna put us in the back patio
area
which is
over here
let's see
oh that's nice
it's nice yeah it's a nice view it's
comfy
oh thank you for the pan
okay Mama what did you order so this is
fried olives oh it just looks bomb I
know you can that looks like a Sriracha
mayo or something too my name Marina I
just saw olives I'm like sign me up this
one is a Kudo tuna yeah Google meaning
like papers I love Capers that's
what got me and then I think there's
like some plantains oral chips he said
otaro
um
do the honors Mama yeah yeah dude that
was on us you're gonna take a bite
maybe one bite yeah
huh
can I have that other bite
oh okay never mind
so MIA wished she ordered this it's a
short rib raised I'm not too sure I just
saw broccolini and me and I was like
let's do it that looks so good
and then Tech we've got some Gourmet
looking those are the best chicken
noodles I've ever seen they look like
fishes
[Laughter]
and I actually can make it fit I got a
side of asparagus and I didn't know
asparagus oh okay I don't know it's
inside a restaurant with like this
yeah maybe a whole plate of veggies I
didn't know it's gonna be like four
veggies yeah yeah so I'm gonna have to
go back to hotel and eat some more food
later but
it looks great though yeah enjoyed
oh it's awesome
flavor
enjoy it dude
all right
back at the hotel gonna finish off my
day with a brown sugar Bubba it's 25
grams of protein just one scoop as you
can hear got the monkey man in the
shower
you this guy is dead Mia's eating I'm
gonna wind everything down but tomorrow
renting a boat and we're gonna explore
all of Lake tunnels I'm really excited
about that me too so stay tuned for that
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
oh
good boy
hey